is andrew garfield the werewolf or not
all right guys so here's the dlio this
one's going to be a little bit different
today as we all know there was that
andrew garfield leaked set photo and
then it became a leaked video came in hd
quality and a whole bunch of people sent
this to me on instagram and twitter how
i trolled the entire internet andrew
garfield deep fake basically there's
this guy out there who did a video
showing that he's actually the one who
did the deep fake on this right now from
my understanding a lot of people don't
believe this guy even though his claim
is taking off right now so i was like
all right how about we do a reaction to
this give our quick thoughts and then
there's another video that got sent my
way of people being like don't believe
that guy watch this video
all right and it's basically how this
guy's going out of his way to showcase
how it is totally a lie
what this guy is actually saying we're
just gonna draw our own conclusion after
this i already believe andrew garfield
is in this film i i fully believe it but
the question is about that one clip so
here we go let's let's watch them both
and give our thoughts
first one is from the channel alex
serato how i trolled the internet andrew
garfield deep fake
huh
wait a minute
where do you get the body from
i don't want the hand particularly
yeah
if it was fake yeah
huh
maybe
full right there
okay
[Music]
here's my suspicions first off just from
seeing that really quick so fast hey
where'd he get the body from and b it's
a lot easier to work this backwards yeah
i was gonna say that
you know like if the clip already exists
it's easier like i don't know how to do
it but i know people who can you can
like what's the
puppet is i i think what it is basically
just remove him work this all backwards
and then put this video together i'm i'm
not sure there will be a corridor crew
on it soon enough yes i'm sure but yeah
i could see like if you had an image
already of andrew garfield in this suit
then you could easily remove it swap it
out for a different andrew garfield face
and walk us all
like this guy could just be trolling
right now and imagine he is either way i
mean it's it's a convincing really quick
one but you haven't fully sold me on
this let's just immediately hop on to
this next one so here's the other one
that was said to be by captain sting
let's just play it and see what he has
to say
people have done just that they have
shared it with me
[Music]
gameplay frame
yeah see exactly yeah that's what i was
thinking you could do that
i mean this guy's really disproving it
right away
oh boy
did a simple roto-rotoscoping of
andrew's body and separated it yes
this has become our worst
[Laughter]
i think both these channels are in
cahoots
this is crazy to me this is happening
the same rotor process in the face make
it
face to fake it is if he took it from
somewhere else
some fake ass show off shitty and wrong
vfx techniques
that's awesome
you need a base actor footage of some
kind simple puppet pin out yes
yeah on there it's a great answer
wow
wiggly
[Music]
this guy basically just went out of his
way and strongly proved how this is
oh hey
yeah
this is interactive's body that's adam's
apple head casting
[Laughter]
oh geez that was hilarious oh man yeah
the extra hands definitely
but they do look like different webs on
even the fingers at the end of the day
if it's a d fake it would have there
have to be a different body in there
right yeah we need some body to put the
face there and you would have to have a
face that already kind of looks similar
in shape and structure to andrew
garfield's face
i mean i'm sure a big thing that keeps
being brought up is like well if it's
real how come people are getting their
videos taken down i'm like
this video of andrew garfield all over
youtube it's been like that for days
like there are videos with like hundreds
of thousands and one that i saw that has
like a million views
so they've been up for a few days and
sony hasn't done jack [ __ ] about it you
know that's the biggest thing that makes
me wonder if it is fake yeah that have
been out of all this i'm like well
everyone's been saying that but then
it's like but they but to be fair they
have definitely taken it down from some
accounts and have copyright strikes some
accounts as well so you know that's what
makes it the the the argument a little
muddy it's like something somewhere in
some words sony was like you know
what'll save us time is if we just
produce a video saying this is fake
i mean after seeing both
like i'm i'm not gonna give the like
after us who have looked at so many
different kinds of crazy leaks to some
that we totally believe are fake and
some that we totally believe are real
i'm not here to you know talk [ __ ] on
the guy who made the one who's like
sorry guys i trolled y'all i'm not here
to talk [ __ ] on him like
it's a great trip it's a great troll
yeah i mean like i didn't really buy it
but yeah i totally believe that this
footage of andrew garfield is real 100
oh yeah the second
the neck against the suit all the little
movements yeah oh but that was a that
was fun though
i just think it's hilarious that we've
gotten to this point yeah it's so funny
both are true on multiple timelines
until the movie comes out he's in it and
he's not in it
all right guys well what did you think
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
click that bell hit that like button
thank you to everyone who blew up my
social media this is just such a weird
thing to be like i think you just gotta
check out both yeah there's a sign for
yourself you appreciate you guys you
guys are awesome that i really do thank
you guys catch you guys soon
[Music]
you